[Applause]
this is ultimate bucket list where
everybody gets to do something on their
bucket list we decide what belongs on
the ultimate bucket list are we doing it
doing it we are here in Las Vegas Nevada
it is hot in a summer so excited theme
today water an element fun fact I can't
swim at all there's gonna be a challenge
that yeah I think I could win
I'm literally making you a different
creature what does that mean what are we
doing mermaid school can we do that
parting some research you can definitely
do it we just like we're gonna wear
tails see you'll see I am gonna be I
think a beautiful I think you will too
really yeah yeah I think you have all
the makings of a great roommate poor man
my man Murr Dan all Merdan how often do
you get to say that like I was a mermaid
hi my name is Kat and I am your aqua
mermaid teacher to learn how to swim
like a mermaid today yeah we're at
mermaid basically we fit you off to a
tail to your size and then we will be
learning something called the dolphin
kick it's kind of like doing the worm
but in the water
so I've done a lot of body rolling in
the club but not in the water because I
cannot swim so will I drown today you
will not drown because you have us well
I get a good Instagram picture from
there that I can a hundred percent
guarantee you will you know what that's
the only questions that is those are my
main concern let's get you guys fitted
for your tails mermen
[Music]
hard enough why not try something
different be non-human for today be a
magical creature I'm a beautiful mermaid
now I'm excited to pull on a tail and
look beautiful I'm a little concerned
about essence she's already a mermaid
just living on land even though she
can't swim old and nervous one hand on
top of the other one like this right oh
god I'm falling over I think I've got
grace you know I would consider myself a
graceful person
[Music]
dad-dad
I have to put my money on anyone it will
be Jeff he's naturally more athletic
she's got it we don't have to teach her
anymore she's good
yeah I'm not even underwater and I'm not
even swimming flipping my fins alone is
stressed in my core out but after this
I'm gonna take some good photos that I
can deliver okay something that I've
wanted to do since I was a little kid so
we are going to go surfing how are we
gonna surfing Beach I will tell you how
we're gonna serve in Vegas and we are
going to go to the Planet Hollywood
hotel we are going to ride the FlowRider
at me at Hollywood hotel though here's
to achieving Dan's childhood dreams hey
what's up guys my name is Matt East I'm
a pro flow boarder from Las Vegas Nevada
here at the FlowRider today get you guys
surfing on some waves in the desert when
I learned to surf I don't want to be
sitting around on a board just waiting
all day for the perfect wave to come
trying not to get eaten by sharks I
don't want that I want this we do a
little bit of boogie boardin with a
little bit of stand-ups kind of like a
skateboard without wheels nice even
spread stance about shoulder width apart
with your knees bent you want to keep
your shoulders hips straight in your
in your writing easy enough wrote and
I'm not in a body of water so I will not
be drowning I'll learn how to surf
before I can swim for the body board
your elbows on the board you lean to
your left and you lean to your right I
saw some pros wiping out so yeah so what
does it take to be a good flow board not
falling that's the best way
awesome it's coming out at 32 miles per
hour I guess they're stronger than the
average wave you could get on a normal
day I don't know don't quote me on that
relax be cool keep your weight on your
back foot you'll cruise when I fall is
that gonna hurt it is a sheet wave
technology it is basically a mat with
nothing underneath
[Music]
cool I'm gonna try and be graceful
and this is finally gonna be a childhood
dream come true
[Music]
they did it for like two seconds hundred
divided by cells
[Music]
[Music]
so like I can't even lie actually my
favorite part was wiping out I could
wipe out all day again
again and Jasmine like again like how
are you so good at everything you do
[Music]
[Music]
we're in a boat
we're a boat ma I'm on a boat
hi I'm Jamie I'm here with Las Vegas
watersports to see how you guys are
excited to go skiing today yeah super
pumped this is clearly not my idea
because I'm I just see danger all around
I will say that it is absolutely
stunning and breathtaking the Hoover Dam
is like just over that way and we're
gonna learn how to water-ski like that's
everything summer bucket list water
bucket list national park bucket list
how hard is waterskiing it's really not
too bad
if you have previous experience with
other boring sports it definitely helps
with the balance and whatnot
usually when we have people out here it
takes like five to ten tries I think
there are absolutely no circumstances in
which I would get into this water the
biggest tip that I have is a lot of
people try to pull in on the rope as
they're getting up let the boat do the
work that's really the biggest tip I
have make sure that you keep those
elbows nice and relaxed because what
usually happens when you pull in is a
pitch over the front so don't do any
work just kind of hang out there and
it's gonna do work for you exact sign me
up this sounds great
I think it's gonna be really thrilled
seeking and relaxing at the same time on
this Zen plane
[Music]
No
[Music]
and do better our dear friend Jaime said
that jazz was off to a good start and if
that was good I don't want to see bad
Oh God dan is gonna be wonderful and
graceful he's gonna look like a
butterfly in the sky on you know gliding
over a lake I think that we've seen over
time that light Grace and balance is
like maybe not what I'm great at I just
want to stand up on those skis for like
a second and then I'm happy to just like
sit back and relax
[Music]
yeah I mean I would count that you're up
on top of the water just one boy
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
what a day
the mermaids your equal partner made
when you're in the water and when you're
on the rocks and so it's like perfect
for everybody
surfing my childhood dream come true and
then Jasmine Waters that took wipeouts
to a whole other level just so beautiful
- absolutely breathtaking what do we do
- we like count to three I got I got
mine one two three like obviously from
me hell no but for the people watching
this absolutely like it was the best
experience all around such an adrenaline
rush but then your face goes directly
into the shoe go for a hike no hi you
guys want to go to the strip
[Music]